I'll give you a great example
of a liberal ridiculous op
the January 6th committee is now
referring Donald Trump to the Department
of Justice
for criminal Insurrection charges
now this is a committee
made up only of Democrats
nominal Democrats and
de facto Democrats
they're urging the doj to consider
charging Trump with inciting or aiding
an Insurrection Democrat rep Jamie
Raskin announced this referral he
described it as quote
a grave federal offense anchored in the
Constitution itself and then he noted
this was automatic grounds for
disqualifying some room from holding
state or federal office
these people they don't give up they
don't give up they don't
2015. I'm gonna say Donald Trump he
can't run for office he slept with
models and porn stars you know that
thing that we've all known about him for
decades you know the thing that um
a pretty prominent recent Democrat
president did very publicly and
scandalously y'all Trump he's
disqualified and then what he colluded
with the Russians so he's disqualified
and then he colluded with the ukrainians
even though the ukrainians hate the
Russians and the Russians anyway they he
colluded with both somehow and he's
disqualified and he's an insurrectionist
and even though no one involved in the
Capitol Hill Riot has been charged with
Insurrection at all because it's just
ridiculous uh he he's he can't run now
and he's a total loser and everyone
hates him and there's no way he could
ever win and that's why we have to do
everything we can to prevent him from
appearing on the ballot that doesn't
quite add up to me
what should the GOP take from this
well the GOP can mock it I think it's
good to mock the jacket the John you
worry six commission it's very funny to
mock that and it's good to do that the
GOP can ignore it okay that's fine the
GOP can get angry about it that I don't
I don't know why I I wouldn't get angry
it's such a joke I mean doj is probably
going to pick it up they've been all
going after Trump for seven years now
but
whatever you know I mean it's just not
these aren't serious people they don't
have principles there so there's no use
getting riled up about that what I think
the GOP should do
is
use these kinds of operations against
the Democrats I think I would humbly
propose especially as the GOP is about
to take control of the House of
Representatives saw some of my
Republican Congressman friends yesterday
at TP USA I would recommend as the GOP
is thinking about
investigating Hunter Biden okay that's
fine where the GOP is talking about
investigating Dr fauci yeah I think
that's good I think we should
investigate Dr fauci
I think the GOP should investigate and
potentially prosecute
Democrat politicians
for incitement against the GOP
for even potentially Insurrection I
think they should they should do exactly
to the Democrats what the Democrats are
trying to do to Republicans the the
Republicans have far better grounds to
do it to the Democrats Democrats like
Maxine Waters have incited violence have
call explicitly called for violence
pushing back on people in public going
to Republican politicians homes
against the GOP against the conservance
Chuck Schumer said we're coming for you
Neil Gorsuch we're coming for you Brett
Kavanaugh and what happened liberal
takes a bus from California to
Washington DC and tries to assassinate
Brett Kavanaugh drag Chuck Schumer
before that committee drag Maxine Waters
before that committee drag all these
Democrats drag Kamala Harris who bailed
out the rioters during BLM drag the
Biden Administration staffers who bailed
at the Riders the violent people during
BLM who encouraged the BLM rights drag
them accuse them of incitement to
violence accuse them of insurrection
accuse them of all the same stuff that
they're accusing us of make look I think
there's a much stronger case
that we have to make against the
Democrats on these grounds but even if
not even if it's all just a big joke
then make a bigger mockery of this than
the Democrats did
just shove it in their face or what are
we going to do we're going to roll over
we're gonna investigate Hunter by and
we're gonna find all all sorts of
perverted things on the laptop none of
it's going to stick
Joe Biden is not going to be held to
account for anything
and then we're going to lose the house
at some point and then nothing happened
no
fight back against this nonsense show
them that you are not going to take this
lying down
what matters in politics is winning
we want to win
in a just
moral legal way
but assuming all of those things
we have to win
we don't want to lose
we don't want to lose with dignity
as some of the squishes often want us to
do
there isn't usually very much dignity in
losing with dignity
you see this principle articulated by
Donald Trump and we now know this
because hope Hicks
was giving testimony to the January 6th
commission and hope Hicks explained
her disagreements with and the advice
that she gave to and the response she
heard from president Trump
after the election
the select committee has obtained
testimony from new Witnesses who've come
forward to tell us about their
conversations with ex-president Trump on
this topic here is one of his senior
advisors hope Hicks
being
evidence of
fraud on a scale that would have
impacted the outcome of the election and
I was becoming increasingly concerned
that
we were damaging
um
we were damaging his legacy what did the
president say in response to what you
just described
he said something along the lines of
um
you know nobody will care about my
legacy if
I lose
um
so that won't matter the only thing that
matters is
is winning
putting any particulars aside about
Trump's Behavior after the 2020 election
I know some people think he fought like
hell and that was a great thing and some
people say no he didn't present proper
evidence of Fraud and so what he did was
irresponsible and it it hurt his chances
of running again okay whatever that's
not what I'm talking about right now
that we can have those disagreements
the principle that Trump is articulating
here
according to Hope Hicks who is a very
trusted advisor of his
is correct
what matters in politics
assuming we're all operating within the
bounds of justice and legality morality
what matters is winning this is a
principle that was articulated best I
think by cocaine Mitch who love him or
hate him the man knows a lot about
winning the man is very very good at
wielding political power
and cocaine Mitch said in response to
one of his opponents
you got Pablo Escobar Mitch over here
versus the DEA of his opponents and he
said
the winners go to Washington and make
laws and the losers go home
say hello
to my little friend
and that's what he said and the last
part I assumed that's what he was
thinking
he's right about that
the winners make laws the losers go home
nobody is going to give Trump a pat on
the head and say well he look we called
him Hitler for four years well like five
or six years actually and
we fought him every step away and we
impeached him twice we just hate him so
much but he
he had a great legacy one termers don't
get great legacies even if the liberal
media pretend to like them a little bit
as a way to attack whoever the presently
dangerous Republican is in the long run
one termers don't really get great
legacies okay what matters is winning
and doing and succeeding
Trump was totally right did it matter in
the end I don't know it remains to be
seen because he's running again in 2024.
the rest of the show continues now uh
today is not music Monday but we're
making it music Monday because you know
I'm a pop Maven we're I was on the road
yesterday it was a little tricky to do
the member block so uh Ben Davies says
that I am now going to complete the pop
music Trifecta we have done T Swift
we've done the Biebs now we are moving
on to Ed Sheeran if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]